with the u.s. and Iran edging
dangerously close to war president
Donald Trump proclaimed that Tehran
appears to be standing down truck gave
no indication that the United States
intends to strike back hours after
Ronnie and missile attacks on two bases
used by the US military in Iraq we
suffered no casualties
all of our soldiers are safe and only
minimal damage was sustained at our
military bases it was a stark contrast
to the president's threats of
retaliation without hesitation that have
dominated his Twitter feed in recent
days instead flanked by top advisors and
Generals Trump made a surprising
suggestion that members of NATO to
become much more involved in the Middle
East process it was an astonishing claim
from a president who once called NATO
obsolete he also encouraged us partners
and allies to abandon the jcpoa an
agreement put in place in 2015 by world
powers to limit Iran's nuclear program
we must all work together toward making
a deal with Iran that makes the world a
safer and more peaceful place however
Trump did announce new sanctions would
be coming without giving specifics he
also left open the possibility of
diplomacy speaking directly to Iran's
leaders he insisted the United States
desires for Iran a great future one that
you deserve one of prosperity at home
and harmony with the nations of the
world the United States is ready to
embrace peace with all who seek it but
missing from the President's speech
evidence that the u.s. killing of
Iranian general Qasem Soleimani was
justified and necessary to prevent an
imminent attack on Americans it's
evidence
opposition Democrats are demanding from
the Trump administration also absent a
clear strategy something the
administration is promised to provide
and closed-door briefings on Wednesday
two members of Congress including top
Republicans Iran didn't just take an
off-ramp they took a u-turn because they
know they have no capability to fight
against America at least based on the
presentation that was made it does not
meet what I consider to be an imminent
threat but if President Trump chooses to
respond by sending even more soldiers to
the Middle East he breaks a major
campaign promise to pull the United
States out of what he once called it's
forever wars
Kimberly hellcat al Jazeera the White
House